all right Adam Adam where'd you grow up
are you from originally
Los Angeles California born and raised
spent some of my younger years in
Northern California in Sonoma County
when my birth parents split up and end
up moving back to Los Angeles and you
tell me about your childhood you had
both parents
well my father stayed in Northern
California my mother and I moved with my
stepfather who was George DiCaprio my
mother met George in San Francisco she
was in a guerrilla theater dance troupe
called FreeStore that was led by a man
named Vito Politis who at one point in
the late 60s was part of the lovin
movement and drop in you know get high
the whole sixties thing in little Canyon
with the mothers of invention and Frank
Zappa right and they they started the
first love ends in Griffith Park and
this guy Vito was a a sculpting
instructor at Barnsdale Park actually in
Hollywood and in the late 60s early 70s
a lot of the hippies from that movement
moved to Northern California in Sonoma
County Vito was one of them and started
this sort of vaudvillian
theater dance troupe my mom was a part
of they did these really elaborate acts
you know that were costumed and
choreographed and everything and they
would perform on stage in Berkeley and
San Francisco and Union Square in his
public places and they were sort of like
political satire anti-establishment like
likes kids and stuff like that there was
one actually where my mom assassinated
Santa Claus in fishing net stockings in
high heels
and it was pretty cool and so this is
called free store a free store was
actually a Shack the view had built in
this little town in Sonoma County called
catotti where it was like a goodwill it
was like a homemade goodwill it had a
sign on the top that said free store I
think would go and drop [ __ ] off and you
could go and pick things up clothes and
toys and stuff like that so anyway my
mom was a part of this dance troupe she
met George they hit it off we moved back
to Los Angeles and shortly thereafter
after coming back to LA I started to
work on television I got work on TV
commercials there was a girl in my first
grade classes mom was a manager and she
met my mom at a PTA meeting and told my
mom that I was gregarious and outspoken
and articulate for my age and then I
would do good to go see this agent as an
actor yeah in support of this occasion I
was murdered to go see her so you can
find me we go out on auditions she did
she signed immediately and I started
going out on auditions and and making
good money so we grew up in Los Feliz
writing Los Feliz east of Hollywood you
know in a little house on a little white
craftsman house and Lea lived with his
mom one block over kind of our houses
were separated the backyards were
separated by like a dirt lot this vacant
lot all they did in the and the winners
was this old Christmas trees in there so
your stepbrother is Leonardo so when I
was four that's about four between four
and five as when we moved back to LA and
my mom and they've been married ever
since I've never had any more kids never
had any other other siblings or anything
besides he and I and my dad remarried
and he lived in Northern California
and I would spend summers I would summer
vacation specific occasions I would
leave LA I'd get out of LA I go to
Northern California and spend with my
dad so I had this really magical
fairytale like you know time in like
summer vacations hanging out in Sonoma
County that's remembers me in the 80s
you know with BMX bikes and smoking
really did pot and having a teenager
like swimming in the Russian River and
and creeks and stuff when the water was
still clean when we didn't get ear
infections and stuff swimming swimming
holes actually you know swim in the
rivers and the creeks and stuff when I
was a kid and yeah it was a really
really special time then my grandmother
hmm moved my dad lived in LA actually
everybody grew up in LA and then some
move to California my grandmother on my
father's side lived in Mendocino the
town of Mendocino and that was
beautifully spent Christmas is up there
every Christmas we go to the town events
you know and my grandmother would in
this one hundred thirty-five year old
Victorian house this real old of the
cool house up there on the headlands in
this historic town where the California
so close there's something a great
childhood yeah it was cool growing up so
it was it was both we got the dichotomy
of you know living in Los Angeles and
experiencing that I kind of burned out
on acting when I when I was young it was
a lot it was you know get out get out of
school and go on auditions and that was
everyday know so as a teenager 15 I
remember around 14 15 I started burning
out and I got into skateboarding and I
kind of went to that instead and Leo you
know little brother he uh he saw me
doing that somebody making money we
didn't spend any of the money this is a
little caveat is all of the money that I
made when I was acting since we were on
food stamps and Welfare growing up all
of that money got put away as a ward of
the court and the judge oversaw the
account so any money was going to done
anything with that account the judge had
to oversee you have a court order to do
anything with that money so when I was
18 I got had all of the money that I
made acting it was like 186 thousand
dollars whole day no so I'm 48 now so
there's a big gap fair enough so 18 so
I've handed that money actually partido
you know I had a really good time with
some of the money for a little bit then
tried to go to college didn't really
work out join the army went off to the
army for four years
yeah the army for four years did two
tours in the first Gulf War
Desert shield/desert storm
stationed at Abu Dhabi Air Force Base in
Saudi Arabia so there's two tours in the
first Gulf War in four years at Fort
Benning Georgia
and got out of the army went to college
went to Pasadena City College for two
years and then transferred to USC and
what therefore tweezers coming back to
my work to do this and then for a little
while for some time worked for my
brother right around this time was when
Titanic came out so I actually started a
company it had to do with it's called
the fan effects we're gonna do fan
sections of websites and official
merchandising and everything like that
for celebrities and I started that
company based on you know his success in
Titanic company actually did really well
we made like a million dollars in the
first year and I ended up just selling
off the company and taking like a
$80,000 severance pay that was in the
90s and the 90s I started partying a lot
in Hollywood clubs and stuff in
Hollywood doing a lot of drugs that's
kind of progressed you know as the years
have gone by yeah when it drugs really
get into the picture for you um well
they were always in the picture but it
was always just sort of pot growing up
no it was always pot and I'd say I guess
in the 90s you know after 95 96 around
those years just hanging out more in
clothes we're in Hollywood drinking and
stuff like that same up on I you know
but really no serious you know regular
addictions or anything like that more
sort of just like partying and binge
drinking and stuff like that
opiates and real addiction and stuff
like that for me really took over more
I'd say like in the last ten years
something like that yes it's like
2008-2009 somewhere around there it was
there - kind of lame what was he doing
playing around with heroin before that
or is it Yeah right there was it used
socially I'd been able to use casually
here and there
I used cocaine ecstasy drank of course
you know in the pot there goes pot a
little bit of meth you know there was
was a really good color glass back down
it was glass but uh never really never
really had one drug that really it
really got me that you know spend every
day going and getting money and buying
and scoring like I am now with with
heroin or fentanyl now but now it
switched over phenol no it's not heroin
anymore now well do phenyl now yeah
strange but you have to be careful with
that yeah yeah you knew for the most
part yeah you have to be careful so
regulate how much really small amounts
and stuff you know but you still have to
be careful I thought was out in our town
on hand so that EOD I need one time yeah
one side of me I've been in jail for
about eight or nine days this is one I
still didn't heroin and I did a shot I
get a 11.00 point one zero
you know amount of black heroin a shot
and I went out and planked out when I
fall down on it seized up a little bit
hit my head cut on the bathroom counter
on the way down and they give you one
dose of narcan and the one does the
narcan brought me back like ten minutes
later I was fine I was awakened I felt
fine
because if if your pipe if your system
is cleaned out you're truly OD'ing and
you get an arc and you don't go into
like this horrible force withdrawal like
if you have a bunch of dope in your
system and and and you get an arc and
you go to this horrible withdrawal yeah
but I didn't get that it have you been
clean I've been working on getting
cleaned up and back and forth back and
forth with it for some time around so
struggling with it I want to get back
into the good graces of my family and
charity my wife and I have a 12 year old
daughter together who's living down with
my mom and I want to have her back in my
life you know so I've been
and trying to get you know aside from
the place that we have we rent the room
but I'm trying to get my own housing
going on going through that whole
process through housing and social
security and all that and getting those
services set up
I am service rated disabled through the
VA also I get disability through the VA
and I'm working on getting SSI so I
already have benefits through VA and I'm
getting that monthly currently already
so well my way to getting things set up
and getting it's taking some time but
what is what is what is fentanyl
fentanyl do for you it's somewhat
similar to heroin I mean that they
basically replaced the heroin addiction
we started doing heroin that had a lot
of fun this is basically the same sort
pretty much the same the same I the same
kind of get down the same they have to
keep it in your system or you're gonna
get sick if you stay ahead of the
addiction and it was simply just a way
to check out basically with to kind of
just stay down for the most part amazing
I mean New York sound like you have some
childhood events that you're trying to
gnome out not particularly no more just
sort of the pain I mean I do have the
separation from my family I don't really
have that connection and that you know I
don't really have that closeness with my
members except for my father he's all
the way to my mother's in Hawaii now I
like my blood father but yeah they sort
of have you know distance me and black
sheep me and variety you know
yeah marginalize me your drug addict as
it were yeah was driven drug addict and
the family drug addict yeah it's always
one that's so I think I don't need to
trivialize it and it's
the sadness I mean it is what it is you
know it's my choice I take
responsibility for it and I don't I
don't I don't really point the finger at
any childhood event or any you know
abuse or molestation or anything for the
most part you know our parents provided
for us well even though we were on food
stamps and Welfare they still notice the
movies and amusement parks and family
outings on weekends and hiking in the
hills and lots of stuff you know Turner
you know culture does parades and
different events and you know social
events and different cultural events
around around the city growing up you
know museums and there's a lot to
experience and I'll add there used to be
this big thing called the street team in
downtown LA it was really close sweets
well block off for concerts and stuff
now is there anything that like having a
wildly successful brother that there
definitely at one point when I when I
stopped working for the fan affects the
company that had made out of college
when I kind of went off and did my own
thing there was a little bit of a
turning away a little bit of a pity
party sort of a thing it's kind of like
having a wildly successful father and
you're right you can never turn away you
know screw this I don't you know I don't
need this it's like the ultimate like
you know [ __ ] you you know I don't need
you know I mean I don't want to be a
part of this and then walking away and
then hoping that somebody comes in you
know and invite you anyway I have all
the way up until recently I was doing
pretty well I was working and working in
television production
I'm actually local 44 in the Carpenters
Union for uh you know for TV commercials
music videos
mhm so I work on sets on a set decorator
and a carpenter and a builder and a prop
guy and I do all that stuff I'll be
doing
since 2002 I worked on my first video
who worked on a $0.50 first video
wangster home they're right over here on
eighth enormity and that's how I kind of
broke into that whole industry was
working on a little bunch of hip-hop
videos but first eyes that we're just
getting into the industry and then
actually that's 50 cent took off
that's his career took off so did
instead of a bunch of us who are working
in that business at the time we were
able to kind of piggyback off of his
success and move up in that world which
was kind of cool so I've done that for
quite some time and I could go back to
that and my family would take me back in
probably and probably have a trust fund
and all of that you know but I just have
to stay clean the main thing is they
just they want me to be cleaning my mom
kind of got wind that you know that I
was I was hooked on heroin and then I
was kind of just spinning my wheels not
really moving forward and she made a
couple of phone calls when CPS came and
she was able to to get custody of our
daughter which is okay she's taking good
care of my parents live right over not
far from us in Silver Lake and they got
a big house at the pool and the
screening room you know so she's able to
have friends over have movie night and
you know pool parties and everything so
it helped hold your daughter plus 12
years old Robin just does you know you
with us all the way up until like four
or five years ago you know you guys are
done here cheers I know we're downtown
he doesn't know specifically we don't we
don't talk specifically all the time our
mother has more contact with her than I
do then you but your visitor on so know
we leave what we've stopped doing
visitation we're at the point now where
it's it's been a long hard battle we
burned through 15 close to 20 thousand
dollars in attorneys that haven't been
able to do anything I'm just gonna take
your money you know twenty thousand
dollars they just gotta laugh at that
that's just kind of like an ante up kind
of an amount you know and so we've gone
through hell with with court battles and
custody courts and stuff like that and
we're still working on it but we're kind
of defeated right now we've got
we feel we feel a little bit conspired
against by the system and and by the by
what seems to be some type of corruption
within the system and the ability of our
parents to manipulate you know
manipulate the powers-that-be to to get
what they want basically you know so
it's just kind of defeating and then
deflating and
you know energy draining you know so
yeah it must be but so sometimes you're
staying here in Skid Row yeah yeah we're
sometimes yeah sometimes for days at a
time we'll be we'll be down here where
do you have a place in Silver Lake where
we go where we stay sometimes to you but
you know just because of lack of having
enough drugs or whatever wolves
sometimes will just stay downtown and
you're staying in a tent or I have
stayed in tents we do have very various
places where we stay indoors we have
rented rooms in different places and
have friends that have SROs and when it
gets really cold you kind of try to
figure out where to go indoors
I do have gifts till my money saved or
you know but I do get monthly I have to
get money every month from the VA for my
disability still so you'll have income
done so I am able once a month that you
get a chunk of money yeah sometimes you
get hotel rooms but nothing really
steady you know it's just kind of
sporadic we just kind of take it by take
it day by day you know like last night
we stayed in a staircase in a warm
staircase in this building this loft
building we know the code for we went in
and it was carpeted and nice and warm
and nobody bugged us witless sleep
through the night and left in the
morning left to clean and no harm no
foul that's great that's great but I
talked to your wife last week and you
guys both seem like a great couple
you just said my people were just there
you just homeless broke out they just
happened to be this little side thing oh
by the way yeah you're both seem
competent and intelligent and yeah king
of all addictive it all of that you know
capable of having normal lives or just
choose to have this lifestyle what is I
mean what is it people don't understand
about addiction drugs I just for me I
don't I don't really make any excuses
for it I like getting high and with this
drug getting hives inside the drug
unfortunately you have to keep it up you
can't just use it and then take some
time off you have to stay at it so it's
like an investment of time and
everything but what is what it is it's
just for me it's a choice I I like any
high I chose to get high on that drug I
choose to continue to get hide that drug
unless I take some time and actually
detox I know what it really takes to get
off of that drug I can't just snap my
fingers and get off of it it will take
time and you know setting some time
aside and having a place and the ability
to go to detox do that I do it when I'm
in jail it's pretty much a lot of us
that's what we did we detox woman yeah
yeah jails jails the way a good cleaning
when we're in jail and then some of us
say we're gonna stay clean when we get
out some of us don't but yeah it's rare
that we do we that's a common common way
people get clean yeah yeah probably the
only clean time for the last four years
I've had was the time I was in jail ya
know it's it's I think that the the draw
that drugs like heroin and crack have on
people it's just so strong that yeah
it's really it's really a commitment
it's it's sort of just like most
accepted it's like so like okay well
here we go again you know all the [ __ ]
that comes along with it it's not even
so much they're doing the drug and the
drug itself it's all of the other stuff
that comes along with it making money
having money who's gonna have the drug
who's gonna buy the stuff that I'm going
to steal from the store to get the drug
it's all about other [ __ ] all those
other relationships all that stuff that
that becomes you know time-consuming
takes up everything it takes up your
whole time your whole day whole night it
becomes everything becomes your life
yeah
a lifestyle and it is all the other
stigma that goes with it right and then
there's the judgement of people and
stuff like that and sort of just become
this I don't even really think about
that so much because like you said when
you first look at me what a lot of
people look at me
I'm able to like keep my image up and
keep T myself I can get cleaned up and
put on nice clothes no you could totally
pass for cover it up straight as an
arrow exactly yeah it's one of its one
of the things on my crack or alcohol or
something like that everyone is one of
the things you can definitely keep it is
it is it do you think it's pretty common
I asked your wife this is it pretty
common you know outside of Skid Row you
know are there people using heroin and
fentanyl yeah you know there's a
downtown that are downtown is a small
very small percentage of the actual drug
users that use that drug most of them
are out other places Hollywood the
valley and they're their left side
they're trying to function as yeah just
just trying yeah just just still doing
still doing a deal you know Santa Monica
has a big homeless population and
Hollywood does too hmm there's a lot of
people that have just kind of dropped
out but the people have jobs and still
use these drugs yeah yeah absolutely
I've been a commodities broker I've done
sales and there was a guy we used to sit
behind me he would not on every day as
he go
fentanyl patches stuck to his chest and
this was like 2010 2011 something like
that I don't even use don't even heard
it yet at the time but people were
already starting to use it back then ten
years ago it's been about 10 years it's
been popular about 10 years it's really
gotten you know start music
next time Adam thank you so much for
talking to me absolutely no problems
player very interesting all right
anytime we should listen again sometime
more than once
yeah maybe I'll have you guys in
together yeah interesting all right cool
thank you
you